vamos a medir la cerca con ardillas y
biceps la cerca tiene una longitud de 10
ardillas y aquí lo puedes ver tenemos la
cerca y tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
ardillas muy bien ahora vamos a medir la
misma cerca de qom ponys así que déjame
bajar la pantalla y aquí lo puedes ver
tenemos 5 ponies de largo 1 2 3 4 5 y
nos preguntan por qué se necesitan menos
ponies para medir la longitud de la
cerca y nos dan dos opciones los ponies
son más largos que las ardillas o los
ponies son más cortos que las ardillas
bien si subimos de nuevo la pantalla
para ver esta imagen puedes ver que por
cada pony tenemos dos ardillas de largo
eso quiere decir que los ponies son más
largos que las ardillas y entonces se
van a necesitar menos ponies para medir
la cerca qué
así que vamos a ponerlo los ponis son
más largos que las ardillas y vamos a
comprobar muy bien vamos al siguiente
ejercicio y es este que tengo acá dice
problema de práctica este es un
rectángulo muy bien aquí tenemos un
rectángulo vamos a medir la siguiente
línea azul usando tanto rectángulos como
una regla graduada con centímetros y
aquí lo podemos ver esta va a ser mi
línea de azul y observa que la podemos
medir en centímetros o en rectángulos y
ahora me pregunta la línea mide cuántos
rectángulos del árbol bueno pues vamos a
contar los 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
rectángulos de largo así que lo voy a
escribir aquí 12 rectángulos de largo y
bien vamos bien y después me dicen las
líneas miden cuántos centímetros de
largo bueno pues si observas la regla
que está
en centímetros vas a ver que mide seis
centímetros así que lo voy a poner aquí
mide seis centímetros de largo
comprobamos y vamos bien así que vamos a
ver qué más dice el ancho de cada
rectángulo es que un centímetro es mayor
o menor el ancho de cada rectángulo que
el de un centímetro
bueno pues regresamos aquí para saber
que por cada centímetro tenemos dos
rectángulos lo que quiere decir que un
centímetro es más grande que un
rectángulo porque por cada centímetro
tenemos dos rectángulos así que un
centímetro es más grande que un
rectángulo o dicho otra manera el ancho
de cada rectángulo es menor que un
centímetro muy bien vamos a comprobarlo
de lujo y vamos a ver qué más nos dicen
entonces se necesita un número espacio
en blanco de rectángulos que de
centímetros para medir la línea se
necesita un número mayor
o menor de rectángulos que de
centímetros para medir la línea bueno
pues lo podemos ver de nuevo aquí si
observas tenemos dos rectángulos y seis
centímetros entonces hay más rectángulos
para medir la misma línea que la
cantidad de centímetros así que hay más
rectángulos que centímetros se necesita
un número mayor de rectángulos que de
centímetros para medir la línea muy bien
vamos a comprobar de lujo estamos bien